bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans sa zone
qu'a dit ce matin nous allons parler des
yoles l'inscription des yoles de la
martinique donc au patrimoine immatériel
culturel de l'humanité
via l'unesco et pour en parler notre
invité alain clôt de l'agît bonjour
bonjour monsieur k oui bon je vais aux
auditeurs vous êtes le responsable
ici en martinique du comité de soutien
d'abord puis comité de pilotage de
laguiole à l'unesco c'est l'expression
que conte un peu résumé pour donc
désigné ce dossier alors d'abord une
précision avec l'au-delà gier parce que
moi même
en m'adressant à vous dans l'invitation
j'ai parlé de les yoles rondes et vous
m'avez corriger on m'a dit non il s'agit
des du dossier des yoles de martinique 1
c'est ça la yole de martinique à
l'unesco
et pourquoi pas la yole ronde parce que
par exemple ont dit tour de martinique
en yole ronde
c'est ça la yole de matinée qu'est
entrée à l'unesco et nous avons tenu un
véritablement insisté là dessus parce
que en fait il ya plusieurs types de
viol plusieurs catégories les jeunes le
savent pas parce que nous sommes
beaucoup nous nous connaissons la yole
ronde qui a le tour de martinique des
yoles rondes mais il ya aussi la plus
connue et la survenue voilà mai mais
depuis toujours il ya eu différents
types d'ailleurs laguiole plateaux des
causses de olten et nous n'avons pas
voulu donc exclure une catégorie de yole
à paul anka l'unesco et donc nous avons
effectivement donne un terme générique à
laguiole de martinique pour que personne
ne se sente exclu d'accord donc laguiole
où les yoles même on aurait pu dire
aussi les gosses de martinique alors
c'est un dossier
il faut le rappeler qui est ancien de
plusieurs années il a fallu dix ans pour
avoir cet aboutissement donc et qui est
survenu le 17 décembre dernier puisque
c'est la date de la décision officielle
finalement de l'unesco d'inscrire donc
la yole de martinique au patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité 10 ans c'est deux
travaillent pratiquement plus de 10 de
10 ans de travail effectivement depuis
la jeunesse de l'idée qui est qui a
commencé avec des passionnés diol qui se
sont dit pourquoi pas faire la gueule
entrée au patrimoine culturel de la
france
patrimoine de l'unesco et puis dix ans
de travail notamment de
travailleur acharné qui est doit-il
auguste donc notre chef de projet qui
acquit initiateurs de 2 du projet
identique qui a fait qu'aujourd'hui bien
nous avons travaillé nous avons fait des
démentis nique et des personnes autour
de nous de différents horizons pour
arriver aujourd'hui à à ce que la grèce
soit inscrite par le comité
intergouvernemental 17 décembre dernier
au patrimoine culturel immatériel de
l'unesco est donc là c'est fait c'est
définitif ça y est on peut dire mais nos
acquis ces acquis et c'est le premier
les mains du patrimoine martiniquais qui
rentre à l'unesco
voilà alors on va le dire la yole ronde
de martinique est inscrite au patrimoine
culturel immatériel mondial de l'unesco
c'est ça c'est ça est important parce
qu'il ya des catégories où des registres
et elle inscrit dans le registre des
bonnes pratiques les blocs qu'est ce que
ça dit finalement de nous-mêmes quoi
c'est ça c'est les bonnes pratiques de
sauvegarde
en fait il faut que les gens comprennent
que ce n'est pas la yole en tant que tel
qui ont enterré l'unesco mais surtout la
pratique de laguiole et les savoir-faire
des charpentiers de marine
c'est ce que nous avons voulu mettre à
l'unesco s'est beaucoup on parle de
patrimoine immatériel
c'est à dire les ceux qui pratiquent la
gueule et toutes les valeurs qu'il ya
autour de cette pratique un valeurs de
solidarité m'excite des valeurs que
porte l'unesco et puis aussi donc les la
la la sauvegarde des de la fabrication
parce que ça c'est important
vous avez une fabrication qui n'est pas
faite sur plan qui est fait de façon
empirique c'est à dire que chaque
constructeur de viol à son schéma dans
sa tête et ça se transmet comme ça de
génération en génération donc c'est
quelque chose d'assez extraordinaire que
voros et si j'en viens là qui sont sur
l'eau qui naviguent tellement bien mais
qui qui sautent simplement de la tête
des constructeurs qui sont relativement
rares aussi d'ailleurs oui bon faut-il
le rappeler bien sûr c'est un patrimoine
vous l'avez dit rich précieux d'autant
plus que c'est c'est quasiment pourquoi
dire quasiment c'est unique au monde
finalement c'est quelque chose qui est
particulier singulier à la martinique et
que la martinique offre finalement au
monde à l'humanité voilà nous le faisons
reconnaîtra l'humanité notamment
ce monde de la mer ce monde de laguiole
qui qui qui mérite cette reconnaissance
parce que souvent les gens de la mer les
marins pêcheurs etc ne sont pas mis en
avant et c'est ça aussi la démence et
mettre ce monde en avant qui nous fait
vivre ces moments forts comme le tour
des yoles comme les causes du dimanche
où tout le monde adhère eh bien c'était
ça c'est aussi ça les mettre en avant
leur donner une reconnaissance je crois
que c'est ce qu'un petit peu tous les
êtres humains héros cherche une certaine
reconnaissance et là ils l'ont et c'est
acquis alors cette ferveur évidemment
populaire autour de la dalle de laguiole
a asservi bien sûr cette démarche ce
projet cela dit il ya encore quelques
personnes qui regrette que le gommier
qui fait partie aussi du patrimoine
marin je dirais de de la martinique
n'est pas été associés qu'est ce qui a
bloqué bon est-ce qu'il faut toujours
poser finalement cette sorte de
concurrence entre bon c'est vrai
d'ailleurs les devenu plus populaire au
fil des dernières années mais le pommier
dont l'origine est finalement au pôle '
at-il rappelé et des kali'na qu'il
utilisait et c'est donc bon voilà alors
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut
rajouter le gommier ce qu'il faut faire
notre dossier
si vous êtes là pour parler du golan on
l'a souvent weezy on l'a souvent même
parfois rocher oui bien sûr il faut bien
comprendre que ce sont des passionnés de
golf
l'idée maintenant les passionnés de
gommiers peuvent tenter l'opération
puisque je suis ouvert à tous nous
sommes nous sommes des bénévoles qui
avons à mener ce projet donc nous sommes
prêts à donner un coup de main à tous
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'éléments du
patrimoine martiniquais ont pour effet
rentré à l'unesco d'avoir cette
reconnaissance
donc je crois que c'est à eux s'ils le
souhaitent et bien nous sommes à leur
disposition comme tous les éléments du
patrimoine
alors le comité de pilotage doit se
transformer en association
c'est ce qui est prévu pourquoi qu'est
ce que ça induit comme changement en
fait ils tombent de feld le comité de
pilotage c'était pour l'inscription
maintenant qu'elle est acquise et bien
au passé un autre étape où il faudra
faire vivre cette yole pendant toutes
ces années parce que il faut rappeler
que la
l'élément qui entrent au patrimoine et
rivaz a lieu tous les cinq ans ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut que cette yole vive
et donc nous sommes en phase de mise en
place d'une association en bonne et due
forme qui va justement de voir continuer
le travail continue et les animations
autour de laguiole et s'assurer de la
véritable sauvegarde de ce qu'est lier
parce qu'elle est entrée au patrimoine
comme elle est aujourd'hui il ne faut
pas que ce que nous avons fait entrer
change fondamentalement donc nous sommes
là poussent aussi poète que des gardiens
en quelque sorte de s'étiole alors
quelles sont les prochaines étapes
finalement une fois que maintenant il ya
une inscription
qu'est-ce-qui quelle mission finalement
il reste à faire et puis quelles
retombées finalement également du point
de vue bon du tourisme
est ce que pour vous c'est ça promet des
retombées économiques est absolument
pour le pays c'est essentiellement ça et
les autres co candidature à l'unesco
sont aussi sur la même longueur d'onde
c'est à 10 s'agit d'avoir des retombées
il n'y a pas mieux que ça parce que ceux
qui voyagent cherchent des éléments à
visiter et donc lorsqu'ils vont sur le
site de l'unesco
il voyage en fonction de cela donc ça
rois des tombes est au top et peut-être
pas immédiat nous est venue de la
situation mais tout a très rapidement et
d'ailleurs l'organe d'évaluation qui
propose qui valide la candidature attire
l'attention de l'état qui présente la
candidature donc la france sur la suite
parce qu'il faut mettre les conditions
ils peuvent y est pas ce que ça implique
effectivement un certain nombre de
droits finalement cette inscription mais
de devoir aussi peut-être oui oui non
pas que le livre tombe est justement que
les touristes viennent et puis qu'il
n'est pas ce qu'il faut donc il faut il
appartient à l'état de mettre en place
ces choses et avec l'adac notamment nous
travaillons à cela et nous allons
poursuivre le travail est donc la suite
c'est ça c'est c'est mettre en place des
actions autour de laguiole nous nous
ferons un festival de sculpture sur
sable
nous en avons fait un l'an dernier il y
a un avenir est l'objet c'est de battre
le record faire une sculpture de six à
huit mètres sur la paille de
saint-pierre probablement nous allons
vous tenez informé tout ça
faire des courses à la godille faire des
animations autour de cette yole et puis
que tous les martiniquais et tout le
monde de la mer justement c'est prennent
la yole c'est ça appartient aux
martiniquais ça n'appartient pas à un
comité de pilotage par exemple donc il
ya un défi qui continue qui ai toujours
trouvé c'est celui de continuer à
fédérer encore davantage en martinique
bon on imagine que les certaines
communes du littoral bombe on pense
évidemment françois robert etc mais
enfin voilà les communes de l'intérieur
qui n'ont pas de mer etc doivent y
participer les les pouvoirs publics et
où les différentes collectivités bien
sûr les communes
oui les 34 pourquoi pas la ctm etc
le comité martiniquais du tourisme enfin
tout à fédérer tous fait des demandes
autour de ce projet et pour terminer la
fédération des yoles rondes aussi
peut-être qu'elle est évidemment un
positionnement alors vous vous n'en avez
pas mais on en pouvait en dire mais nous
sommes en ce qu'ils sont et ce qu'ils
ont fait ce que cette fédération des
yoles rondes en martinique a vocation à
être votre partenaire absolument ils ne
sont déjà il ça sera le cas dans
l'avenir parce que on ne peut pas
imaginer faire sans eux puisqu'ils sont
quand même ce qui promotion s'étiole
depuis des années donc nous allons poché
dans ce sens avec eux bon ben voila
merci avec l'au-delà j d'avoir répondu à
nos questions autour de cet événement
qui date on le dit officiellement du 17
décembre dernier puis là nous avons
visage et donc les perspectives
après sainte inscription officielle de
laguiole 2 martinique au patrimoine
culturel immatériel mondial de l'unesco
dans le registre des bonnes pratiques
jimmy oui tout à fait on a raison d'être
fiers de s'étiole en plus on est les
seuls à l'avoir en tout cas et à l'avoir
maintenu comme ça et c'est aussi rendre
hommage aux premiers aux anciens qui ont
fait vivre ces viols pendant pendant des
années merci à vous bonne journée mais
aussi revoir